[Music]
how do you craft the perfect
assassination
your first time will probably be a
little awkward maybe you kill the guard
who surprised you
and then you have to kill a witness and
the witness to you killing the witness
and the guard who caught you stealing
his friend's clothes
soon this can all become very messy
each location is like an intricate
machine that invites you to stick a
crowbar into anything you like
admittedly these things tend to be
people
but more elegant solutions demand more
ingenuity and lateral thinking
each location is designed to be played
and replayed
not because you die before killing your
target but because you'll notice so many
temptations
and every time you successfully
assassinate your target
things change suddenly
instead of a crowbar you have a scalpel
or a sniper rifle
or a rubber duck
agent 47 could be anyone anywhere
anytime
so maybe you craft an unfortunate
accident
or perhaps you design a rube goldberg
machine of devastating complexity
the choice is yours also unique to
hitman is its life-changing nature
hitman's groundbreaking elusive targets
are a perfect example of this
an opportunity to assassinate a target
that disappears after a few days
and can only be attempted once hitman
will make you think like an assassin
each door could hide a murder
and each balcony can be a tragic
accident waiting to happen
locations are built to explore enjoy and
toy with
we will never stop challenging you this
is our world of assassination
you